Host: Good morning, everyone, and welcome
to this new talk about
Leadership at Google. I'm extremely honored
and also grateful to receive our
guest. He was the -- the first speaker on
the first day of the [inaudible] of the
program at Columbia. And, uh, 20 months later
was voted by, uh -- was nominated
by the students to be the keynote speaker
at the graduation ceremony. I think
that says something about his talent as a
speaker. His class, "High Performance
Leadership", is consistently one of the best
ranked if not the highest ranked
class at Columbia Business School. He spent
20 years at Pepsi as Chief People Officer.
He loves cashmere and good wine. Please welcome
Professor Feiner.
[applause]
Michael: Hi, everybody. It's nice to be here.
It's nice to see such a large
crowd when today is opening day for the New
York Mets. Umm, uh --
[laughing]
Michael: For folks in Kirkland, or Mountain
View, or Seattle, that's a baseball
team. Uh --
[laughing]
Michael: Uh, so I wanna talk to you for a
bit about leadership and I've been
instructed to advise you that -- to hold your
questions until the end and then,
uh, I will be eager to answer what I hope
are questions as provocative of some
of the comments I'm gonna make- uh, today.
Umm, I have a lot of passion for
this subject of leadership. And I would wager
that, uh, anybody who works in
organizational life has an opinion about leadership.
If you ask people to name
great leaders, often you hear the names, uh,
Churchill, for David I'll say
Napoleon, Martin Luther King, JFK... And that's
largely because when we think of
great leaders we think of visible leaders,
uh, leaders that we've either read
about or talked about as kids, it's the way
we're socialized as children. The
fact is that leadership is really like an
iceberg. 90 percent of it is hidden
below the surface. It's the things that we
don't see day in and day out, that
determines whether people are effective in
getting things done in organizations.
It's not about necessarily being a valiant,
courageous, heroic individual, the
way we had typically associate, uh, Napoleon,
or JFK, or Churchill, or Lincoln,
or so forth. Uh, and the fact is that, uh,
we all have opinions about
leadership, uh --
Michael: -- But I think it's important to
review quickly, in my opinion, what
leadership is not about. Uh, I don't think
leadership is about grand strategy.
That may sound surprising for an organization
like Google who I suspect is
grappling now with: What is the business model
over-- within the next five to ten
years? What is the right strategy? In fact
you've probably aware that you have
some folks from McKinsey running around trying
to help you sort that out. Now,
I think strategy's important for any business
but I think the tough part of
strategy is not formulating it, it's implementing
it. The tough part of
strategy is getting people-- all your Googlers,
to figure out what is the
strategy; to buy into the strategy; to buy
into the strategy; to believe in the
strategy; to row on the ores in the same cadence
and the same rhythm. So, what
I'm suggesting here the tough part of strategy
is strategy implementation. Not
strategy formulation. Especially difficult
in an organization like Google which
has grown from 300 people five years ago to
20,000. I don't think leadership's
about personal charisma. I -- I -- said another
way. I think leaders come in
all shapes in sizes. Uh, some are short, some
are tall; some dress for success,
some don't; some are modest and self-effacing,
some have big egos. Uh, I think
leadership practices ultimately determine
whether or not someone is charismatic,
not the reverse.
Michael: I don't think leadership is about
inspiring oratory. Uh, I haven't
seen or heard your famous three make speeches.
Eric, Larry, Sergey, I don't
know. But having been around organizational
life for many, many, years before I
started teaching, I think there's very few
people in organizational life who
match JFK, and Martin Luther King, or Gandhi,
or Churchill and so forth. And
finally, I don't think leadership is about
technical skills. I mean, you're all
very smart. Google is famous for having very
smart people and a hiring process
that makes it foolproof that you'll be hired
only if you're very smart. But the
fact is, umm, I don't think leadership's being
the smartest man or woman in the
room. It's quite likely used -- you who manage
groups of people, you may have
people working for you who are more technically
expert. I -- very often
leadership is ant being from time to time
a curator or a conductor, as opposed to
the smartest, most technically expert, functionally
expert person. So if that's
not what leadership about -- is about then
obviously it must be about accurate
planning and budgeting.
Michael: It must be about sound organizing
and staffing; particularly important
the larger and larger and organization like
Google becomes. And finally, about
effective tracking or controlling and problem
solving. That is, tracking how
you're doing against the operating plan and
then of course problem solving or
making adjustments on the fly, when in fact
things like the great recession beset
us. Now, all those things are important but,
particularly important because they
add order and consistency and predictability
to an organization, something that
I'm told Googlers fight very hard to resist.
Michael: But the fact is, as important as
order, and consistency,
and predictability are, it's really what management
is about. And I think
management's important for every organization.
Being well-managed is important
whether you're Google or AT&T. But if that's
the only thing you're good at, you
ultimately become the Department of Motor
Vehicles. You become bureaucratic,
lot of red tape, lot of policies, lot of procedures,
lot of rules, which can be
very unhealthy for any organization. So therefore
it's very important to offset
management-- with leadership. And what leadership
is about is really establishing
direction, Whether you're running a department
or not, whether, in fact, you have
a department or not. Establishing direction,
for me, is about the vision and
the strategies to get there. It's also about
building alliances and coalitions
so the product management people, and the
engineers, and the sale -- sales
people actually focus on the prize instead
of fighting with one another, which
can occur in any organization.
Michael: And finally, day in and day out,
once you cut through the game rooms
and the free candy, how excited are you about
your jobs and about coming to work
here, and about collaborating with the people
in the next cubicle? That
motivating and inspiring is one of the hardest
things to do in organizational
life. One, for yourself to be motivated and
bring your A-game every day, and
then to make sure that you can get the people
that you're collaborating with or
in fact supervising or managing, to make sure
they bring their A-game. It's very hard
to do. Next to raising teenagers, which I've
done four times, motivating and
inspiring people every day, is very difficult.
I don't know about the people in
California or Washington, but if you take
the subway, the New York City subway to
work every day, which many of you do, and
you look around at the misery on the
faces of the people --
[laughing]
Michael: -- you get a sense that people aren't
terribly motivated and inspired
about going to work. It's actually quite tragic.
Michael: Not so funny. So, if management is
about predictability, and
consistency, and order, then leadership is
about change and adaptability. An
organization like Google and the space you're
in has to be particularly
adaptable given the technology and how quickly
it changes in this space,
adaptable to new technology, new competitors,
new regulation, new competitive
responses, new customers.
Michael: So effective organizations are both
well-led and well-managed. Which
means your challenge is to be concerned about
order, and consistency, and
predictability-- more than you have been in
the past, in my opinion. But at the
same time, worried about vision and the strategies
to get there, and motivating
and inspiring people to bring their A-game
to work. So how do you do that?
Michael: I -- the thing that's particularly
important with leadership is
building "followership", particularly when
this is such a high-transaction,
collaborative organization. Influencing people,
not relying on sanction power and
authority, requires you to influence and persuade.
Michael: So leadership, in my view, is really
about building followership.
It's really about pulling people. It's much
less about the use of power, and
much more about empowerment of others.
Michael: It's really about taking people with
you. And all of that is about
managing relationships. It's about managing
relationships down in the
organization; it's about managing relationships
up in the organization, sometimes
with knuckle-head bosses. And particularly
important here, at Google, it's about
managing collaborative peer relationships.
And all of that takes HTHC. All of
that takes hand-to-hand combat. That is, it's
all of those hundreds of
transactions you have every day up, down,
and across, that gets people to do what
you think they need to do. That's really what
leadership is about. Leadership
has nothing to do with your title as you know,
it has nothing to do with your
sanction, power and authority. It has to do
with influencing and persuading
people to do what you feel deeply is important
to the success of this
organization. That's why oratory, and strategy,
and charisma won't help here.
This is why leadership is just like an iceberg,
right? 90 percent of it is
hidden below the surface.
Michael: So I wanna talk to you about tactically,
very real-world setting...How do
you lead people to excel?
Michael: And just as context, umm, I wrote
a book several years ago called "The
Feiner Points of Leadership", where there
are 50 laws, or rules, or principals
that you could use to motivate and inspire
people every day. And, uh, I'm not
gonna go through 50 laws because you'd be
throwing tomatoes at me by the -- by the
20th. But I'd like to go over ten laws that
I think you can use immediately after
this session, and I think it would enhance
your effectiveness. Umm.
Michael: Law No. 1. This is not a typo. This
is meant to add drama here so
don't --
[laughing]
Michael: Don't get nervous for me. My slides
are gonna -- they're okay. Uh,
this law can best be explained by telling
you a true story. 1968 California
school district, and teachers are told that
certain third graders have scored
very high on a late bloomer test, and to expect
a learning spurt over the ensuing
school year. Lo and behold, at the end of
the school year, not only did these
third graders improve their performance in
the classroom, but their IQ scores
went up-- quite dramatically, quite unexpectedly,
their IQ scores went up.
Surprising? There was no test. It was a ruse.
It was a ploy, it was an
experiment now known as the Pygmalion Experiment
between this very well-known
social psychologist of the day, and this California
school district. What
happened? Teachers were told to expect a learning
spurt, and so as a result gave
these third graders -- who reportedly scored
high on this late bloomer test --
they gave these third graders more time, more
attention, more focus, and more
feedback.
Michael: And these third graders, receiving
this increased focus, and
attention, and coaching, improved their performance
in the classroom. This is
what I call the "Law of Expectations". In
my parlance what that means is, when we
expect people to succeed, they usually do.
Michael: So let me say it another way. People
respond to the level of
confidence you show in them. I would suspect
that in your own lives, given how
successful and how smart you are, this had
an enormous impact because I would
suspect this was the way you were parented.
Michael: The fact is, however, this is an
important attitude or mindset to have
particularly in a collaborative relationship,
where you need ultimately to expect
people to meet or exceed your expectations,
because if you have people working
for you in some cases who don't, they know
it regardless of what you tell them.
It's in the ether; it's in the oxygen. So
if you have some concerns about
people's ability to meet or exceed your expectations,
you better make sure,
because you are a leader, that you provide
the teaching and enabling that's
required so that in fact they do ultimately
have your confidence.
Michael: "Law of Intimacy". It's always amazing
to me when I go into
organizations where I do a fair amount of
consulting and very often leaders will
say, you know, I'm not happy with my team
and I'd like you to talk with my
people to sort out how I can raise my game;
how I can groove my team. And I
talk with the people who work for this leader
and the single biggest complaint I
get is," My leader has no idea who I am, what
I'm about, what I stand for, what
my hot buttons are." So the law of intimacy
is all about yes, being focused on
the task, being focused on the responsibilities,
being focused on the to-do list.
But to lead people effectively, you have to
know your people. That doesn't mean
just understanding the names of their spouse
or their children or their pet.
That might be interesting-- What's more important
is sorting out how to get the
best out of them. Do they like a long leash,
a short leash, a lot of
independence, a lot of transactions? You know,
I have four children. The idea
of treating them exactly the same is preposterous.
Yet, when I talk to leaders
they tell me, listen, I hear you, Mike, but
I treat -- I understand the law of
intimacy, because I treat everybody the same.
This is a very famous- very important
academic concept. You may wanna write this
down. That is the stupidest thing
I've ever heard in my life!
[laughing]
Michael: You ought to be treating everybody
differently, because everybody is
different. Particularly in a place like Google
which prides itself on being such
an iconoclastic culture.
Michael: I mean, the fact is, it's really
important to treat people equitably,
but that doesn't necessarily mean you have
to treat them similarly.
Michael: "Law of Building a Cathedral". You
all know, jobs aren't enough for
the soul. Everybody, especially the people
I see on the New York City subway,
need to feel that meaning and purpose is connected
with the work they do.
Michael: And that's important because unless
you think you're building a
cathedral, you think you're chopping stone,
and no one wants to chop stone. So I
think it's important for leaders in this organization,
which means everybody who
works in it, to make sure they understand
whatever their role, whatever their
job, whether they're an engineer involved
in very nitty-gritty things or not,
ultimately, connecting people is changing
the universe and that cathedral can
compensate for sometimes the maybe boring
or repetitive work that people are
doing.
Michael: "Law of Personal Commitment". This
is real simple. Everybody knows
that you, as an individual, is committed to
doing your work and meeting your
targets. But you have to be committed to not
just your success, your targets,
your to-do list, your role and your responsibilities,
it's about having some
share of mine for the concerns and success
of the people who work for you and/or
the colleagues you deal with every day. You're
gonna get a lot less trust if
people think the only thing you care about
is your success and your targets.
This is about answering e-mails on time; this
is about doing performance reviews
on time, this is about actually being available
to teach when people have a
question.
Michael: "Law of Accountability".
Michael: Yes, you have to be concerned about
your targets. But it seems to me,
for accountable people to own it, they have
to have a performance contract with
the people who they are going to depend on
to get their work done. It could be
on the back of an envelope, but the -- the
performance contract needs to be very
clear and very specific about what are the
requirements that you expect people
to meet for you, and what they need from you,
that can able them to satisfy your
expectations.
Michael: But in a place like Google, when
collaborative relationships are so
intense, and so multifunctional, I think it's
very important to understand the law
of "Pull Versus Push". Yes, you all have strong
points of view and therefore
it's quite normal for you to want to persuade
and influence peers to accept your
point of view --And there's nothing wrong
with that, except if that's the only
technique you use.
Michael: Ultimately, it seems to me, you need
to not only try to persuade and
influence and assert your point of view, which
all of you pride yourself on
doing quite openly, it seems to me you also
need to involve, and listen, and
engage. It might be interesting to kind of
blend with the push approach, the
pull approach which requires as a first question,
"Help me understand why you feel
that way?" And in fact, throughout your work
you ought to be using both pull and
push. If you're using ultimately just push,
like I did for a good part of my
career, people know the pitch you're going
to throw, they know the technique of
influence, and power, and assertiveness, and
ultimately it gets to be a turn-off
for 'em.
Michael: "Law of the Mirror". Very simply:
In a high-collaborative
relationship, in a high-collaborative culture
like this, very often there will
be some conflict. Very often you can go home
at night kicking the cat,
screaming at your spouse or partner.
Michael: Yelling at the remote, because those
knuckleheads at work just don't
get it. In those situations, I would strongly
advise you before you get to the
blame game, to look in the mirror and ask
yourself what you're doing that's
contributing to this relationship issue, that's
contributing to this issue
that's getting in the way of collaboration.
Because ultimately, falling into the
trap of concluding it's their problem, is
a losing game. It's a losing gig. In
fact, usually when there's a relationship
problem, you're both contributing to it
or several people are contributing through
it -- to it, so I would suggest you
ask yourself that question, and then ask the
colleague what is it that you're
doing that's contributing to the problem.
You'd be amazed at how effective that
can be.
Michael: Leading teams. Some of you lead teams,
both officially and
unofficially.
Michael: And so, a good story to remember
about leading teams --
Michael: -- is the story first about none
of us is as smart as all of us.
Yes, teams can take more time, teams slow
down the process sometimes-- but if you have
the mindset that none of us is as smart as
all of us you usually get to the
right outcomes. But the story that I think
is most effective in understanding
teams, is the story about Michael Jordan,
the famous basketball player,
Michael: who was the rookie of the year in
the 1984/85 NBA season.
Michael: And Michael Jordan goes onto win
the individual scoring championship,
that is scoring more points than any other
player in the league in 1986, '87,
'88, '89, '90, '91, '92, and '93. He's not
a bad basketball player. But the
Chicago Bulls never won their first NBA championship
until 1991. So when an
Assistant Coach said to Michael Jordan in
1989 he said, "Michael, you can't do it
all by yourself. You can't carry this team
on your back. You will not win an
NBA championship thinking you can do it single
handedly. Michael, there's no
"I" in the word team." And Michael Jordan
shot back in a flash, "there is in the
word "win"", because to Michael Jordan winning
the individual scoring championship
was just as important as winning the NBA championship.
Implications for you
all, you have to, quote, "read the table".
Michael: That is, you have to understand the
motives and the agenda for
everybody that you're dealing with on your
team, or the team that in fact you're
interfacing with, because no one's agenda
is the same. So "reading the table" and
understanding what the needs, motivation,
and agenda are will ultimately
determine how they play together as a team
and you need to know that. And you
need to know that, and you need to find that
out by watching, and listening very
carefully, because people's body language
ultimately can tell you a lot about
what their real motives are.
Michael: "Law of Healthy Conflict". Too often
in organizational life conflict
is considered evil. But the fact is, conflict's
a lot like cholesterol. There's
the good kind, and the bad kind. And in organizational
life you want --
Michael: -- you need to strive for debate,
and dialogue, and discussion, which I
suspect is not a problem here at-- Google.
Michael: You don't want unhealthy conflict,
where people are vying for power
based on personality, or jealousy, or unhealthy
ambition. But you want dialogue,
and debate, and discussion. This is the lifeblood
of every organization. This
is what didn't take place at General Motors
for about 40 years.
Michael: "Leading Bosses". Whether you think
you have them or not, I have some
bad news for you. Even in this very egalitarian,
flat organization, we all have
bosses.
Michael: And
an important story about bosses is really
about the Law of the
Emperor's Wardrobe. The most important book
ever written on leadership, until
2005...
[laughing]
Michael: You've all had this book read to
you as kids. If you have children
now, you have read -- read or will read it
to them. You know the story, "The
Emperor's New Clothes". This book by Hans
Christian Andersen -- this fairy
tale, was written in 1837. 1837 -- And you
know the story about these two
scoundrels masquerading as tailors. And they
have this -- what they claim is this
spectacularly beautiful gold thread which
they convince the very vain king to
buy, even though it's nonexistent, explaining
to him that only the most
intelligent people in the kingdom will recognize
how absolutely sartorially
splendid he will be in his new costume. And
of course he parades around the
town in the buff, you know the story, until
at the end of the story a child
says, "Why is the emperor naked?"
Michael: Well, here's the message for you
folks. From time to time, hopefully
not that frequently, you're all naked.
Michael: And very often, even in this culture,
it's hard for people to tell you
that they don't agree with your agenda, your
priorities, your leadership
particularly if you have sanction, power and
authority and if you're senior.
So you need to create a very safe place, a
very safe environment where you make
it easy, for people to tell you when in fact
you're not wearing any clothes.
That's easier to do than the second part of
the law of the emperor's wardrobe,
which is telling your bosses when they're
naked. In an organizational life, when
people ask me what's the single most important
requirement, I often demure
'cause I'm not sure there is one. But I think
one of the most important is to
have intellectual courage. That is, to tell
bosses when they're naked even when
they don't want to be told that.
Michael: I think at the end of the day it
takes guts to tell people what they
need to know, but aren't aware of. And I think
for organizations to succeed, you
need a broad cross section of people in the
organization to tell people that, to
tell bosses that. I mean, for years outsiders
knew that General Motors had too
many cars, too many products, a bloated bureaucracy.
Everybody knew that except
the people in General Motors, because nobody
wanted to tell the bosses what they
needed to hear. And I think the future of
Google, in a space as competitive and
tricky, and complex, and fast moving as this
is requires people to have
intellectual courage to tell senior people
that there's some things they need to
know about that they may not wanna hear.
Michael: Last law. And it's the "Law of Values-based
Leadership".
Michael: You know, you folks work hard despite
the game rooms and the free
candy. You're expected to ship, you're expected
to meet the targets, you're
expected to do high-quality work but there's
nothing wrong with that kind of
expectation. And so it's quite likely that
throughout your career, here or
anywhere, you'll ask yourself WYHA: What you
have achieved? 'Cause you're gonna
work hard, you have high targets to meet,
demanding targets to meet, and one
metric, one very appropriate metric is to
say, how am I doing? Am I successful?
How am I doing against my business school
classmates?
Michael: But in fact if that's the only metric
you use, in my view the slippery
slope awaits.
Michael: Which is why I think it's particularly
important to have another
metric.
Michael: That you assess yourself against
just as frequently as WYHA and I
think WYHB, that is what you have become to
be successful, to meet the targets,
is particularly important.
Michael: What values did you have to suspend
to be successful, is all too often
what ambitious people don't ask themselves.
You know, the fact is, in my
opinion --
Michael: -- leaders establish this followership
for two reasons: One, they're
competent, 'cause you wanna follow competent
people. But also it's because of
their character. That is, you believe in their
values, you believe in their
sensibilities, you can trust they're gonna
do what they say they're gonna do.
'Cause in my view if -- if leadership's about
taking people with you, pulling
people, if leadership's about building followership,
then I think ultimately
values are the oxygen of followership.
Michael: Thanks very much for listening. I
appreciate it.
[applause]
Michael: So if you have questions --
Host: Please use the mic 'cause we have people
listening.
Michael: Ah, use the mic. Okay. We have one
mic? Yeah.
Michael: It's usually the first question that's
the most difficult, so I think
we should start with the second question.
[laughing]
>> I'd Love to hear your advice on delegating.
Michael: Yeah?
Michael: [inaudible] delegating, okay? Umm,
well, you know, books have
been written about delegating and, uh --
>> [inaudible]
[laughing]
Michael: I hope you don't do that with my
book.
[laughing]
Michael: Uh, I actually think it's very simple.
Uh, I think it's very -- you
need to be very clear about what you -- what
you're asking the other person to
do. The second part of that is making sure
he or she understands the reason
that you're asking for it. I think you need
to be very clear about the
timetable involved so that the person is,
uh, on the same highway as you are
about time frames. And I think the most important
thing to do at that point, is
ask that person you're delegating to, what
he or she needs from you, to enable
them to own it, and be accountable and meet
the target. Umm, it often falls
off the cliff, when the person says, okay,
I'll get it done but isn't
understanding about why it's important, how
it connects with the cathedral
you're trying to build, or is unwilling to
tell you that there are several other
priorities that he or she has that's going
to make your timetable difficult. So
it's very important to get -- to get that
granular information out during the
discussion. So it needs to be much more than,
"You get it; I want it; it needs
to be done by Friday". That's not effective
delegation. That answer your
question?
>> Umm, I had a question about kind of, like,
can one bad apple spoil a whole bunch,
or can good leadership skills supersede someone
who's possibly slightly toxic to an
environment?
[laughing]
Michael: Uh, yes, I think one bad apple can
be very corrosive and toxic to a
team. Uh, I think it's very important, umm,
before you wanna run them over on
Ninth Avenue, hiring a taxi to do so, I think
it's very important to get to the
source of what is it that's, uh, causing this
toxicity? Is it I don't like my
job; I don't like you; I don't like this culture;
I don't understand what I'm
supposed to do here; I don't think I fit in?
So, uh, I think -- I'm not
suggesting you need to be a psychiatrist,
but I do think you need to get to the
root cause of that. Some of those things are
solvable, some of those things are
not. So if it's something you're doing or
the team's doing that might change
that attitude, you outta try to do so, particularly
if the person talented, and
skilled, and valuable technically. There are
times where you're gonna need to
decide, you're in the wrong -- you're in the
wrong game. This is not the right
game to you and, umm, you need to get into
a game where you're going to be more
motivated, more comfortable, and a better
fit. But yes, one person can -- can
be, umm, can be very, uh, dysfunctional to
an organization and bring the entire
team down. Sure. Yes, sir?
>> You talked about a couple of things. You
distinguished between management and
leadership, which I absolutely get and absolutely
agree with. You also said that,
umm, motivation is -- is really a product
of leadership and I'm kind of surprised
about that. In one way I'm surprised about
that because I've certainly seen
certain -- not here -- umm, management have
immense impacts on motivation though not
positive impacts on motivation.
[laughing]
>> And I -- I -- in my experience I'm -- in
the same sense that some people are
recovering alcoholics, I'm a recovering manager.
Umm, I -- I've seen that both
motivation can come from leadership but I
really think that I've seen leadership come
from what you've described as management.
Now, am I -- does it -- in your experience
can it come from both? Is it really --
Michael: Sure. Sure it can. Sure it can. Umm,
and, you know, there's nothing
formulaic about being motivating and inspiring.
But motivating this gentleman
might be -- require a different set of skills
than motivating this particular
gentleman, which means you need to know who
you're trying to motivate. You gotta
know what's gonna ring their bell, you gotta
know what their agenda is. Umm,
and, uh, I think certain motivation comes
from sensible processes that prompt
people to conclude, gosh, this place, uh,
is reasonably well organized, it's
reason -- it's got its act together, doesn't
have too much freedom and too much
iconoclasm --
>> And consequent -- and the other way around,
from the nonsensical --
Michael: Absolutely. Or it can be so process
driven that it's the Internal
Revenue Service. Right. I think we're in violent
agreement actually. Yeah.
Yeah. Sure.
>> Uh, you use the example of inspiring people
to build a cathedral rather than, uh,
than cutting stone. Well, those cathedrals
took a hundred and 50 years to build or
more, so people were committed for life umm,
the reality is -- today is --
Michael: Generations.
>> Yeah. Yeah. But the reality for today is,
we'll hire you if you already know
how to cut stone and the instant we don't
need you for cutting stone anymore you're
gone. So in that sense -- in that sense, is
leadership in that direction a noble
lie?
Michael: Uh --
>> Or not so noble?
Michael: You know, I think that's one of the
reasons why organizations have a
very hard time eliciting high trust from the
people that work for them. So I --
I do think that's one of the dangers of working
an organizational life today is
that, you know, people don't have high trust
for the "institution". Umm, so I
agree with that. On the other hand, I think
building a cathedral is particularly
important so at the time you're building it,
however long you're there, even if
it's not for Larry, Sergey, and Eric, and
the other Huey, Dewey and Louies around
here, the fact is, you think your work is
meaningful and important and you can
go home at night thinking it's making a difference.
It's -- it's beyond the
specific team or role you play. It's going
to, um, give you some sense of
meaning and purpose. Even if ultimately, umm,
organizations, uh, come to the
realization that they don't need you anymore.
For the time that you were here,
so long as you can feel you were doing something
important, my hunch is you
won't look like most of the people I see on
the New York City subway system.
>> This is a particularly interesting time
to make that point because, uh, if in
fact you gain meaning out of your work, when
you lose the job you're in a lot of
trouble, which has happened with a lot of
people.
Michael: Well, I didn't tell you to gain meaning
from the work you lose your
job. I said you gain meaning from your work
while you're doing your job.
>> Right. But then when you lose your job
what do you have left?
Michael: Umm, the opportunity to find another
job.
[laughing]
>> Right. Which is a severe problem for people
these days.
Michael: Ah, it certainly is. It certainly
is.
Michael: Yes, sir?
>> Umm, First of all, thank you very much
for coming here and speaking to us today.
Michael: My pleasure. Thank you.
>> I think it was terrifically informative
and enjoyable and I might even buy your
book. Umm --
Michael: I have four kids so I would really
appreciate it.
[laughing]
>> So I -- I understand that problem, believe
me. Umm, I've worked for a couple of
companies that, uh, had "naked emperors".
I think that's great advise, but that's
tough. And often that's tough because the
messenger gets shot. Umm, so how do you
go about building that kind of culture? How
do you go about doing that? How do
you go about if you feel that that has to
happen, carrying out that task of speaking
to the emperor, cause I think it's not trivial.
Michael: Well, I think it's a great question.
I think most organizations don't
work up to their level of potential, umm,
because most organ -- in most
organizations, information flows down and
unfortunately not enough of it flows
up. It's so filtered and buffered when it
goes up that, umm, bosses ultimately
don't know when they're naked. Which is why
it's so important for an organization
to understand that are in fact naked or semi
naked. So you're right, it's very
difficult. Umm, courage is difficult, isn't
it? I mean, courage doesn't mean
you're fearless. Umm, fearless people are
stupid, right? I mean, going into
battle in Afghanistan, Iraq, fearless, gets
you killed. So I do thing that --
that the -- that what's tough about, uh, courage
is two things. One, pushing
through the fear, but then to your point,
having the kind of granular skills and
emotional savvy to use the right language,
to establish the right sort of
covenants, so that bosses ultimately know
you're going to push back on them.
Umm, and, uh, there's a whole chapter in my
book, chapter ten, about how do you
push back? What words do you use? What language
do you use? I'm not
suggesting you go into a boss' office and
say, "I gotta tell you, chief, that's
really stupid." or "I gotta tell you, boss,
people think you're a moron." or "I
gotta tell you, chief, nobody agrees with
your priorities." That's not courage.
That's stupid. But what I am suggesting is
being artful, uh, clever,
manipulative with the kinds of language and
the kinds of relationship-building
skills that ultimately allows a leader to
listen to your pushback. Great
question.
Michael: Yes, sir?
Host: Do we have any questions in the remote
offices? Guess not.
>> Uh, thank you very much for coming to speak
today.
Michael: Sure.
>> I have a question -- you may have covered
earlier in your speech but I guess it
has to do a little bit about perception. I
think there are a lot of things with
leadership that people take the boxes and
they're supposed to do this and they're supposed
to do that. Umm, and I think sometimes, you
know, we talk about in [inaudible], that people
confuse being liked with being seen as leaders.
So the disrespect factor. Uh, can
you comment on that and how -- how people
sometimes get those two confused?
Michael: Yeah. I think -- I think there are
a lot of reasons you need courage
to be a leader, one of the things is you have
to tell -- you have to sometimes give people
who work for you or with you some tough love
and, umm, often not met with great
popularity. So I think it's -- I think it's
important for people to respect you
and your values. I think it's important to
treat people with dignity and
civility. But I don't think that's the same
thing as being popular, or well liked,
because being a leader means you sometimes
have to make some tough calls on
people, you have to give them some tough messages.
Now, how you give them those
messages I think is important but I don't
think that leadership has anything to
do with popularity in a sense that you asked
the question. In fact, it often
takes -- it's -- it's often as difficult to
give people -- it's often as hurtful
to tell people what they're not doing well,
as it is for the person to hear it, that
they're not doing well. So I don't think leadership's
about popularity. I'm
not suggesting you need to be a shrink. I'm
not suggesting you need to loan
them money. What I do think is you need to
tell people the truth. It's a great
question. Yes, sir?
Host: Okay. This is gonna be the last question.
>> Okay. Uh, I represent the sales organization
here at Google --
Michael: Uh-huh.
>> -- and I was sitting with a few of my colleagues
and we remarked that, umm,
except for one or two, very few members of
the sales leadership organization actually
came for this session today.
Michael: Mm hmm.
>> How would you advise that we deal with
that?
[laughing]
Michael: Uh, well, first I'd -- I would suggest
you tell them what a fabulous
talk they missed.
>> Absolutely.
[laughing]
Michael: And then I think you ought to ask,
umm, how come they weren't able to
make it? And then you might wanna say, do
you mind 'cause I -- we have -- we have
this, uh, this knucklehead's talk on tape,
or we -- it's a link, can we -- can we
carve out a time to go through it, 'cause
I think there's some concepts he discussed
that would actually help our group--Our group,
not you, but our group, be a
heck of a lot more effective. Can we carve
out some time to do that?
>> Thanks very much.
Michael: Sure.
Host: Okay. It's 1:00 p.m. I think that's
about it. I'm gonna wrap up here.
Thanks very much for attending the talk.
[applause]
Michael: Thanks for your time, everybody.